قاعده بقيت مهجوره لن اشتهرت مجددا عقب
اعلان انتقال قوات فاجنر الى بيلاروسيا
مواقع غربيه وعسكريه روسيه نشرت صور اقمار
صناعيه وفوتوغرافيه لما قيل انه معسكر
يجري انشاؤه في هذه القاعده
خصوصا لقوات فاغنيل القادمه من روسيا اثر
محاوله التمرد العسكري الشهر الماضي
انتقال قوات فاجنر الى بيلاروسيا وتمركزها
في قواعد ليست بعيده عن الحدود الاوكرانيه
كثيره بشان مستقبلها ودورها في هذا البلد
رئيس البيلاروسي الكسندر لوكيشنكا حاول
التبديد بعض الغموض بشان وجود فاجنر في
بلاده
خلال لقاء بصحفيين اجانب ان بلاده لن تكون
منطلقا لاي تدخل عسكري ضد احد مهما كانت
صيغته
حتى اليوم مساله اعاده تمركز قوات فاغنر
ونشرها في بيلاروسيا لم تعالج نهائيا قدوم
فاجنر الى بيلاروسيا مرتبط بقرار الرئيس
الروسي وقاده فاجنر نحن لم نعتدي على احد
واذا تعرضنا للعدوان فسنرد في حال ظهرت
راجنر في بيلاروسيا فانها ستدافع عن بلدنا
على غرار الجيش البيلاروسي
رئيس البيلاروسيه اعتبر كذلك ان من
الضروري الحفاظ على قوه فاجنر لحتفيتها
العسكريه
والاستفاده من خبرتها القتاليه في صفوف
القوات المسلحه البيلاروسيه
احد هنا في بيلاروسيا لشركه فاجنر او
غيرها بان تصبح قوه سياسيه عسكريه كما
كانت في روسيا لم يحسم الجدل بعد بشان
مستقبل شركه فاقدر لا سيما ما يتعلق
بنشاطها خارج روسيا لكن من المؤكد ان
مينسك ستضع اطرا واضحه وحاسمه كما قال
لوكاشنكا تضبط فيها وجود هذه القوه
العسكريه في المشهد السياسي للبلاد
زورج الجزيره بيلاروسيا